[Music]
the third-generation Cayenne may pose
something of a dilemma to the potential
Porsche buyer why settle for two seats
when you can have the same sports car
performance in a five-seater with lots
of luggage space to date over seven
hundred and seventy thousand buyers have
opted for a Cayenne the latest version
comes with a little extra horsepower and
speed but the real changes are to be
found in its technology this Cayenne is
a true child of the digital age
[Music]
the wonderful car tester Klaus needs
leads observes that even if some people
have great respect for a car like this
they'll still see it as a bit ungainly
body says forget all that
the rear axle steering makes this car
extremely nimble and easy to maneuver
depending on how he looks at the new
Cayenne he might easily think nothing's
really new about it at all
but as soon as he sits behind the wheel
he realizes almost everything in here is
new especially the twelve point three
inch monitor he can use to control many
functions the car is always online and
of course he can connect with
smartphones as well under the out de
estar mr online the Cayenne Turbo lists
for around one hundred and thirty nine
thousand euros in Germany it's gotten
two point three centimeters wider
the wheels have all grown by one inch to
a minimum of 19 inches 20 and 21 inch
rims are available as options
the most obvious change to the exterior
can be found in bag a rear LED light bar
and an active roof spoiler the first in
an SUV it provides downforce and helps
to reduce noise
in this generation the most radical
changes were made to the interior
at first glance Porsche seems to have
used everything good and expensive from
its new Panamera the sports car style
seat position is not new to the Cayenne
the back seats to offer plenty of
legroom for tall people
thanks to 6.3 centimeters additional
overall length
[Music]
Klaus has to admit they've done very
good work on the suspension together
with the active role stabilization the
three chamber air suspension makes for
greatly enhanced driving dynamics and if
you really cut loose it rounds the
corners like a genuine sports car a four
liter twin-turbo v8 gives this year's
top-of-the-range model four hundred and
four kilowatts of power the sound is
satisfying the speed incredible and the
feeling intense the Cayenne effectively
conceals its weight and in turbo mode
forgets it entirely
in Sport Plus mode it makes the zero to
one hundred kilometer an hour sprint in
an impressive 3.9 seconds and reaches
200 kph in 14.6 seconds the fear leader
flouse describes this four liter v8 as
truly breathtaking no need for
additional words besides the performance
and response and finds it has no turbo
lag it does have a Blunden sports car
feeling this version is about 50 kilos
lighter than previous ones giving it
greater agility imply Susana fogging her
[Applause]
the braking system has also undergone
intensive development carbon ceramic
coated disc brakes are standard they
make for a far more consistent braking
force to aim for to get other HD honey I
think it'd so what does Klaus think of
the third generation Porsche Cayenne in
his opinion this Cayenne is the best of
the best in its class should anyone need
more power the turbo S e-hybrid has been
announced it's supposed to achieve 680
horsepower
[Music]